for every game you love there's bound to
be somebody who thinks it's the worst
thing ever but several games of
seriously divided gamers between those
who think it's awesome and those who
think it's crap since valentine's Day is
just past let's talk about games we've
got a love-hate relationship with
first let's talk bio where there are
developer who every soften makes a
creative choice that gets a lot of flack
from their fans let's start with dragon
age 2 now dragon age origins that is
dragon age one is pretty widely accepted
to be a slam dunk with such an awesome
first entry it was always going to be a
real tough act to follow for dragon age
2 i'm actually among the people who
liked dragon age 2 but even i disliked
the wild dragon age one had you become
the freaking hero of ferelden and splay
a damn archdemon dragon age 2 crowning
moment of rescuing the far smaller
region of kirkwall felt like a huge step
down story-wise dragon age 2 also
suffered from a massive
oversimplification of the combat
mechanics since it seems Bioware
mistakenly thought gamers found the
first games mechanics too tricky but
thankfully some of that was rectified
for last year's dragon age inquisition
Bioware isn't out of the woods yet
though as I'd be totally remiss not to
mention their most controversial title
among fans Mass Effect 3 yet another
victim of its own expectations now mass
effect 2 is regarded as one of the
greatest rpgs and perhaps games of all
time so the final entry in Shepherds
valiant trilogy had a lot of work to do
in my opinion massive x3 had similar
issues to dragon age 2 the game wasn't
altogether bad in fact it was very good
but it seems like a lot of people still
felt the rayji feelings towards Bioware
since they had in effect asked us to
care so much about mass effect story law
and spectacular universe and then well
stuffed it up the big issue was with the
ending which spawned among other things
a charity drive which called for a new
ending which didn't amount to picking
one of three uncomfortably similar
options that you just SAT through and
lacked any kind of narrative impact fire
where did end up releasing a slightly
better ending which provided a bit more
closure and satiated some gamers but
it's still
memorable sore spot for the series and
an infamous example of what can happen
when you piss off your fans moving on
from bioware we have another
controversial game that earned itself a
two out of 10 from one games publication
and a 10 out of 10 from another it's
survival horror game Deadly Premonition
this is a great example of a cult game a
lot of people found the combat and
control scheme to be simplistic and
clunky which it is but others looked
past that and found the whole experience
of the game to be wonderfully bizarre
and entertaining the plot is certainly
quirky and in some places completely
ludicrous with a sense of humor that
you'll either get really on board with
or will completely leave you behind if
you just don't get it realistically
there are loads of technical issues with
the game including subpar audio and
graphical quality nevertheless the
subject of the strangest video game of
the Year award has been called a
beautiful train wreck and it's huge cult
following proves that one person's
discount bin title can totally be
another's game of the year now if i say
Skyward Sword sucks or Skyward Sword
rocks and you actually know what Skyward
Sword is I'm betting you'll have some
kind of reaction The Legend of Zelda
Skyward Sword like so many of these
kinds of games get a lot of its
criticism from the fact that gamers have
huge expectations and set ideas of the
Zelda franchise in Skyward Sword link
and zelda a childhood friends which
upset those into the established law the
game's progression is more linear than
past games and it employs the use of the
wii remotes motion control the one to
one directional sword slashing these
controls worked very well for some
people and terribly for others some
people were excited to finally be able
to actually swing link sword around
themselves while others just weren't
keen on waggling their wiimotes over the
course of a 40 hour quest a bunch of
critics and gamers complained about the
repetitive locations and quests of
Skyward Sword the naggy Navi asks
sidekick see and the story which just
didn't feel as epic as the previous
entries interestingly even though a lot
of hardcore zelda fans a critical of
Skyward Sword it's been reviewed more
positively across the board than pretty
much any other game I've talked about on
this episode seriously look at those
scores Skyward Sword is a pretty perfect
example of how certain games can divide
audiences so strongly let me know down
in the comments if you reckon these
games I've mentioned are awesome or crap
and if there's any games that you love
that everybody hates or vice versa I'm a
great week and I'll catch you next time